yeah hello room my name is Marcus black
owner I'm a developer evangelist
Nicolle Twilio just out of curiosity
because I see some familiar faces there
who doesn't know what silly ways okay
cool so Twilio is a communications API
that helps developers like yourselves
adding SMS messages voice chat and video
into the applications you always ability
we have libraries for all of our eyes
decays and all of our Oliver a pea ice
so you can just very much you know if
you're a developer for example you can
just very much add the new get packages
into your applications and then you can
get starts using video but this is not a
even though we do care a lot about IOT
this is not a Twitter talk okay if you
want to know more about Twitter we have
a booth downstairs in the third floor
it's next to coffee stand so if you
don't know more about till you just come
and talk to me about it and I'd be more
than happy to talk to you so today I'm
here to tell you about Android things I
just want to kind of take some stuff out
of the way
Android things is this new platform I
there's some information about me on the
screen I will be tweeting these slides
later so you don't need to worry about
making notes or like taking pictures or
anything if you don't want and I also
run Android things like rocks which is a
website or about Android things but let
me just tell you a little bit about what
Android things actually is because so
far you may have had some experiences
with Android which is like you know on
the phone and Android running on a watch
maybe sometimes you've seen it on a
screen maybe your TV maybe a car but
Android thinks is an extension of
Android that lets you move away from
these things and actually have on drug
running on different devices I am going
to talk to you about some of the devices
I'm going to show you some cool demos as
well but I want to I want to tell you
what kind of applications you can use
Android thinks for who's an under ed
developer here ok so not everyone that's
fine like you don't need to be an
Android developer to get starts with
this but basically the some of the
applications Ranieri things right now
things like cameras in gateways in
points of sale
there's people using their own security
systems like you know if you want to
build a security system one that really
sytze me is fleet management so there's
people actually trucking fleet like you
know their trucks and everything and
they have a they have an Android device
that kind of you know it can talk to
androids also and everything but this is
a IOT device that lives inside a truck
for example and and that's exciting
because there aren't that many different
ways you can do this kind of thing right
now okay so there are some IOT devices
out there there are some Arduinos and
everything but all of them have their
own limitations we are going to talk
about limitations today okay so my whole
premise here is I just want to be honest
with you and tell you what this what
this thing is about but why is Android
things actually different because as a
sort of like an IOT enthusiast I have
always been of the minds that okay so I
can get my Arduinos and then there's
something else that comes out there's
like the esp8266 and then you know
suddenly you're like in this deep end of
learning C++ and you you know you're
kind of going back to university times
where it's like for me it's you know
like C++ is okay it's fine but this is
not what I work with okay this is not
the language I am most proficient with
whereas when it comes to something like
Android for example yes I've been an
Android developer for a while so for me
to be able to use the skills I know and
transfer that to go elsewhere so
transfer that to go to a device is very
powerful and this is not just like a
telephone now this is something else
this is a different board okay some of
the things that are worth mentioning on
when it comes to Android things is
everything that I'm like all of the
logos I have here are the logos that an
Android developer will know about okay
so you have the Android studio there of
the androids you know firebase have
Google clouds you have Kotlin so this is
all of the stuff that a an Android
developer who already have okay and you
know fan is when you install the the
first one in there which is under its
video most of these other things kind of
combine those with its okay so there's
no like setup there's no special setup
or anything but I'll show you how to
actually take a device and make sure
it's got Android things running on s
because obviously we will be looking at
devices that don't
thoroughly come with Android things and
you can install it on them so let's talk
about this let's talk about where
Android things actually runs okay
because you know this um like we have a
we have a couple of different boards and
I kind of wanted to go through some of
these boards okay I'm sure some of you
may have heard about NXP as a board and
and an XP they're like really big right
now when it comes to sort of like home
automation and they're becoming really
big when it comes to like IOT like just
building IOT and and busy for the
Internet of Things but the one thing
that the the one thing that nxb kind of
like falls short in my opinion is
there's not really a massive community
behind them okay so when you get stuck
on something when you're like I don't
know using a board like this for example
and you get stuck and you have a
question there's not really that many
people who can ask because they don't
have a massive community but you know
what guess who's got a massive community
these people here raspberry pie they do
have a a really big community they have
been out there for a while and and the
good news is Android things runs on the
Raspberry Pi 3 so the Raspberry Pi 3 if
you if you haven't got a Raspberry Pi 3
right now the Raspberry Pi 3 is sort of
like the latest addition to the to the
raspberry PI's and the cool thing about
this is like it's got a very decent
processor in it it's got some very
decent ram so it's got some very distant
memory and it's about 35 pounds ok so
you're not really making a massive
investments because this is the other
thing as a hobbyist so I'm not a I'm not
a an electrical engineer or anything so
as a hobbyist for me it's kind of hard
to say hey I'm gonna pay 65 pounds on a
boards I don't even know if I'm gonna
use it I don't even know if it's gonna
work you know with the Raspberry Pi if
it doesn't work it can always turn that
into a video game or something so I can
always repurpose that so there's there's
different things you can do with this
but there are more reasons so one of
them I mentioned right there's a massive
community behind this okay there wasn't
a single time when I got stuck with a
Raspberry Pi and if you go down to my
booth you see I'm actually using some
raspberry PI's on the on the big screen
there there wasn't a single time when I
was stuck
the problem with the Raspberry Pi and it
couldn't find an answer like they have a
massive community they have four ins
they have everything so it's kind of
cool to be able to rely on this okay the
other reason I like the Raspberry Pi is
cost okay I am I am okay having a
Raspberry Pi behind my light switch or a
Raspberry Pi behind my door I'm not so
okay you know with literally having a
bunch of money like you know paying
hundreds of pounds in a boss that is
gonna just stay there okay I'm not like
this is you know it's a kind of a waste
of time and it's a kind of a waste of
money for boards it's just staying there
it doesn't do much or it doesn't you
know it always does the same thing the
other reason is and the other reason I
chose the Raspberry Pi personally is you
probably already have a Raspberry Pi on
that junk drawer that you have in your
house okay a bunch of people got excited
about raspberry PI's there's you know
small computers and everything and yes
you know I buy every single one of them
when they come out I don't know if I'm
gonna use them but I buy them so you
probably already have one but this is
you know this is my choice obviously
there are the other boards there are
differences on the boards and everything
but one of the things I want to point
out on the boards themselves is if you
are building for scale if you are
building I don't know like a fleet
management for example you probably want
to go with one of these boards here and
the reason you want to go with one of
these boards here instead of the
Raspberry Pi is the Raspberry Pi is
great for hobbies the Raspberry Pi is
great for like coming up with prototypes
when you want to go professional what do
you want to do is you want to come out
of the boards and you want to get this
bit here which is the processor so this
is where Android thinks is gonna run
okay and if you want to create your own
boards if you want to create your own
your own products you probably want to
go for one of the NXP boards okay we are
not talking about going professional
here we're not talking about you know
Asset Management's or anything we're
talking about let's just get started
let's just get stuck in and you know you
can get your codes that runs on the
Raspberry Pi and run on any of those
boards as well there's no difference
okay so this is a this is super good
because you can basically use all the
pins and the headers and everything you
get here and once you're ready if you
want to go to production if you want to
productize then you can go to one of the
and then you can start analyzing things
like okay so what's the process or how
much rum do I need and everything so you
can start think about these things but
sort of going back to how to get started
okay
getting started with Android things is
really really easy the first thing
you're going to need is obviously one of
these boards okay like I said you can
get a Raspberry Pi for 35 pounds or so
depends on where you buy so it's easy to
get one you know if you go to Amazon you
can find a Raspberry Pi
now the next thing you're gonna need is
a memory card so memory cards is gonna
go on the Raspberry Pi and the other
thing it needs is obviously Android
studio so remember I said most of the
logos I showed you back then you know
with the android logo and katli and
everything when you get Android studio
you get those things embedded in Android
studio okay so you don't need to do any
setups or anything and and that's
basically what you're gonna need okay
now you need to have the you need to
have Android things actually installed
on this on this Raspberry Pi and the
process of getting those is simple
there's a there's an installer that you
can download so if you go to the Android
things website there's gonna be a link
so there's a console you can log into
that you can log into the console and
they're gonna give you a command line
application that you can use to install
Android things into your memory cards so
it's not a like you know downloading
something and they're just writing a
bunch of commands you're just executing
something so you're executing something
like this which is your which is your
setup and you have an option to say hey
I want to do Linux or depending on which
computer you are in this case I'm on a
Mac and it will give you the options
what you want to do then you get you've
got two options this is again this is
with this memory card just plugs into
your computer okay we're not doing
anything on the Raspberry Pi itself yet
so it's gonna go and ask you what you
want to do do you want to install and
dry things and optionally set up Wi-Fi
or do you want to set up Wi-Fi in an
existing Android things so we're gonna
go for option one here which is we want
to install Android things now the next
one is what hardware are you using again
this is giving you the options of which
harder you want to go for
you don't need to do any manual
downloads anymore you can just go
through this and it will it will
download the stuff for you again so
we're using a Raspberry Pi so we're
going to go for option one so we use the
we chose the Raspberry Pi 3 and now it's
gonna ask you do you want to use the
default image or the custom image and
this is really cool this is the part
that really excites me okay because I
talked about productizing and everything
when you go with the default image this
is the basic image this is the vanilla
Android things image but as it turns out
you can create your own image so if you
have applications running on on Android
things right now if you have created
applications you can run you can
basically build your images around this
so when he sets up different devices you
can use your other images so you can use
your custom images okay so in this case
we're not using a custom image we're
just going for the default image okay
it's worth noting as well that when you
have Android things installed on a
device because it's connected to it's
connected to your Wi-Fi or whatever you
can send you can send push updates to it
you can push your updates to it as well
so you can do over-the-air updates which
is also quite nice and many of the other
IOT things don't allow you to do that
and then so we chose we want to do we
chose one of the number one and this is
gonna go like in download stuff for you
so it's downloading Android things for
you so you don't need to know which
version you want to go for it just does
it for you and then it flashes okay now
the one thing about flashing and
everything is this is going way faster
than it actually goes okay I had to
speed this up because otherwise we would
take the whole hour here to to show you
that and then at the end it will go
ahead you want to set up Wi-Fi and this
is basically when you're going to set up
the Wi-Fi for this device if you want to
skip it you can skip it and then you
just go to when you're ready to set up
the Wi-Fi you can just go and set it up
okay option 2 on the on the very
beginning you can just set it up worth
noting if you want to have it plugs into
a an Ethernet cable for example then Co
you can you can also have it plugs into
a cable now I said this before but it's
important to keeping my
that when you install this it is gonna
take forever
okay like forever is it takes about 20
minutes to go through the whole process
right and this is why I had to speed
this up
so it takes a while I also I suggest
when you're installing this just let it
go just let it be and when it's done it
will tell you one then now you know you
can start using but once once you're
done you're gonna be presented with a
screen like this okay and I say you're
gonna be presented with a screen like
this because you will need to plug this
thing to something like you need to plug
this to an HDMI monitor for example you
need to plug it into something so you
know what's going on it's not completely
necessary for you to plug it to
something if you know what you're doing
but I like to always plug it to see that
okay I've done the installation and it's
so good like it so good stuff and
everything and in this case I'm
connecting to an Ethernet cable and
because I'm connected to an Ethernet
cable I've got an IP address already
okay but this is all like the theory and
everything so I feel like I should kind
of show you a little demo of how this
thing works okay and this is obviously
where things can go wrong
but I have a backup in case things go
wrong so I'm going to come out of my
presentation mode here and what I want
to show you is I have I have this little
camera here and this camera is right
here okay so you can see my finger here
and I have a Raspberry Pi there so I
have a Raspberry Pi
it's a Raspberry Pi with a button it's
plugged into my computer so it's all set
up it should be running it runs as an
Android device what we're going to try
to do is we're going to try and build
the simplest application ever and we
want to make sure that okay we've got
everything that is needed to run this
thing so I am gonna I am going to reset
my
I'm gonna reset what I have in my codes
here so I'm gonna end up with nothing
okay well I'm ending up with a sort of
blank Android application I didn't want
it to go through the process of seeing
me creating an Android application
because it's basically new Android
application so this is what you end up
with the first thing you're gonna do is
you're gonna import Android things into
it so importing Android things so it's
compiled only then Android things latest
version of it and I'm also gonna bring
in a button which if you're an Android
developer you will know that there's a
button library inside of Android and
this is the widget so this is basically
when you use a button in your
application this is a different kind of
bus and this is a driver button okay
we'll get to it in a second you
understand everything but for now just
stay with me and I'm gonna sink it and
the next thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go to my manifest because Android things
only ever runs one application at a time
so unlike your telephones for example
you have mobile applications running
with Android things what you're gonna
find is that sometimes they don't
actually have a screen so when they
don't have a screen how these how do you
go and switch applications so Android
things runs best as a single application
device the other thing about it is
sometimes they don't have a screen
sometimes you don't have a button
sometimes this is only that thing that
is behind your door and it's doing
something so you want to make sure that
when you start your Android application
you want to make sure that you start the
application as well because there's no
user interaction there sometimes and and
the way you do this is you just create a
new intent so I'm gonna create the IOT
intent so this is basically me saying
hey when my androids things device boots
up I want to start this application
that's the first thing I'm gonna do just
go ahead and start the application now
again I have a blink activity here if
you're an Android developer you know
this is what you end up with when you
create a new Android a new Android
application okay so blink activity so
this is just a blink class and what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna check what GPIO I
have
and I'll tell you all about GPIO s but
if you want to know right now GPIO s are
basically all the pins you have access
okay so these are the general inputs and
outputs pins that you have access in
this device and I want to check them out
so I want to see which ones I have okay
so I'm gonna start off by creating a a
variable here I'm using calling by the
way you can use Kotlin or you can use
Java it's up to you Colleen is my
preference but you can use either one of
them okay everything you will see here
including the links there will be there
will be links to repositories where you
can see the codes and you can also see
the Java code in that if you want so
it's it's really down to preference here
so I'll create a variable called service
and on this variable I'm gonna use the
pre fro peripheral manager service okay
so this is basically bringing the
peripheral manager service from the
Android things package and I'm gonna do
a real simple thing here which is GPIO s
and now I wanna do service that GPIO
list okay so I just want to show that I
have a list of general purpose input and
output items here so I'm gonna run that
as you can see it's already picked up
that I have an Android device connected
again the Android device is this little
Raspberry Pi here okay it is it has been
configured with Android things so it's
already picked up and now when I press
ENTER it's gonna do its magic so great I
was like trying to build this thing and
hopefully the Wi-Fi will help as well
because this relies on the on the Wi-Fi
right now and it's installing the apk so
now it's launched and you can see at the
very bottom here it says GPIO is on
sorry it's really small but it says GPIO
s and then you have a list of all the
GPIO so you have a list of all the pins
okay so this tells me cool that thing is
working like it's installed okay so
that's the that's the first part of its
but we're gonna carry on we'll come back
to these in a minute so like I said I
did have a backup just in case mine's in
more so this is just a video that shows
you how this thing would have worked but
you know it works so we're all good but
the one thing that you will know is so
far we have been very hardware free like
we haven't really done anything with
this like we have a Raspberry Pi there's
a button connected to it but we haven't
used like we've only just like boots at
this application and we haven't actually
used the bus and we haven't done
anything and this is the part where I
feel like if you have never done
anything to do with IOT if you have
never built any I don't know robots or
like devices or anything this is the
past where like I I feel like I should
tell you what some of the things are so
we talked about the peripherals before
the peripherals again these are the
inputs and outputs pins that you can use
so this is basically what's in a
Raspberry Pi okay so you have some
voltage places here like 3.3 volts and 5
volts grounds and you've got the all of
the BCM s here are the pins that you can
use for inputs and outputs then you have
some different things like spi and
you've got you've got PWM so depending
on what you using the pending on what
kind of device so depending on what kind
of hardware you using you will need to
use different buttons or different pins
on this okay so when I say GPIO just
think about these pins here the next
thing is bread boards so I think that
the and you're gonna come across these
things when you start sort of playing
with IOT so bread boards is basically a
blank canvas where you can do all of
your prototyping and everything without
having to solder anything if you have
done any soldiering before you will know
that it's a it's a kind of a one-time
process like if you mess it up you can
you know you can this solder it but it's
a kind of a one-time process so I
usually say starts with a breadboard
because if you literally just pluck your
your your cables in it
can use it and you're not doing any
soldering okay once you're a hundred
percent sure of this and you want to
turn that into a nice-looking boss then
you can do all the soldering jumper
wires again jumper wires is what's gonna
go between the breadboard and your
devices this could be maybe the pins in
here or this could be something else
this could be like a sensor or something
resistors are you know they help us with
reducing the flow so if you have this is
basically a way for you to control
resistance like if you have a 5 volts
for example when you try and push 5
volts into an LED something is gonna
happen blaze basically some black smoke
that it's gonna smell really bad
it's the same idea of like having a
hundred ten volts and you connect it to
one hundred two hundred twenty volts
something is going to burn or explode
then one thing that is really important
about resistors is and I found you know
I found this out the wrong way or the
hard way the colors actually met her
okay
colors are important so they're not just
good looking things with like nice
colors colors actually messes so there's
values in them and there's websites that
help you learning these things I feel
silly saying this now but yes when I
started I was like oh my god they're all
the same like there's just a bunch of
resistors and they all have nice
different colors colors actually matter
okay so this is the resistance that you
can apply and LEDs the blinky things
okay so I think we've all seen or plays
with LEDs but they're basically the the
blinky things like you know the lights
light bulbs and stuff now the other
thing that you are going to come across
is you're going to come across some of
these schematics just like this one so
this one is called freaks Fritzing and
Fritzing is a free open-source
application that helps you come up with
schematics just like this okay now the
good thing about this one is it's very
visual so even if I have no idea what
I'm doing when I look at this I can
literally just so this is like you know
copy and paste I can literally copy
stuff from here into my breadboards and
it will work usually so Fritzing is
basically what you can use to I don't
know if you build a library for example
you can use Fritzing to actually show
people how to connect how
to plug things in some of these
schematics you're gonna see out there
are way more complicated than Fritzing
but Fritzing is a way for especially
people who are like starting now it's a
way for them to you know learn it's a
way for them to be able to understand so
you will see a bunch of those examples
especially in android things you will
see a bunch of these examples using
Fritzing now we're gonna try and emulate
this sort of like how this thing works
so I'm gonna put up another demo here
and on this one we're gonna we're gonna
stay here on the same place we were
before what we are going to do though is
we're going to create a variable for our
button okay remember with with imported
buttons here okay so we're gonna create
a variable for it I'm gonna do this as
lay in it and I'll call this button and
this is going to be of type button again
if you are an Android developer you will
know that Android widgets is the regular
button that you get in an application
for hardware you shouldn't be using the
widgets you should be using the driver
button because we're going away from the
screen we actually have a physical
button here so we're going to select the
second option here so we now have a
button now what do we do with the button
we can initialize it and with this birth
so we're gonna go button and button asks
for two arguments it asks for a pin so
pin again going back to GPIO so it's
just the pin number of that specific
GPIO I have in this device here so as
you can see I don't know if I can zoom
in yeah I have no idea oh maybe I can
yeah that's right
cool let's make this bigger as well
so so I have my wires sorts of them
connected to three pins here one of them
is the GPIO and the other two the blue
and the red are the positive and the
negative okay
so this is what the this is what the pin
consists of in this case we'll come back
to this in a minute so I know by looking
here I know that my button is connected
to pin B cm5 so I'm gonna say cool this
is connected to B cm5 and now I want to
say what happens when I press this
button like what sorts of logics the
logic states do I have when I press this
button so we're gonna go logic States so
I've got a button so logic state I can
have pressed when low so one a thing I
want to say this button is pressed when
I really press it or pressed when high
so this is basically me saying I want to
do something when the button is down not
when the button is up because you could
do something when the button goes up as
well so we're just saying pressed when
low so when the button is down I want
something to happen now I'm gonna take
this button and I'll just create an
event listener so again same thing in
every single language like I'm just
gonna go and create an event listener so
in this event listener I want to do I'll
just get this so now instead of starting
the application and writing to the
bottom how is it like we didn't hear I
once that every single time I press that
button I want to log a message
okay so again super simple but it kind
of goes to show you that yes it is meant
to be simple it's meant to be that
simple like there's not you know there
shouldn't be any magic here so I'll go
ahead and run this again and this is
probably gonna like remove
the activity ball it's gonna kill the
activity and then it's gonna install it
again so it's like it's falling right
now and then as you can see you look at
the bottom here and nothing really
happens like you don't have that log
anymore like you can't see that log
anymore and the reason you can't see
that log anymore is because we haven't
really pressed a button so hopefully now
again my fingers here when I press the
button you should see that something
happen at the bottom right there on the
logs so that's the best source of viz
okay so I'm like controlling a button
now I have something else the the
hardware that you see here is basically
the same kind of harder that you've seen
on my slides on that Fritzing thing so
I've got a resistor there I've got a
button so this is just like a bigger
blue button but it's the same idea okay
and I'm just plugs into three places
I've just got my my think plugs into
three pay places and this is what the
breadboard is okay it's just a different
color as well so now we can control
buttons right and you see where I'm
going with this in a minute so let's go
back to the slides and again I had a
backup for this just in case it didn't
work but let's just have a look at the
codes let's have a look at what we have
because of this I I kind of feel like
when you when you're dealing with
especially external hardware like you
know dealing with software is fine
because software doesn't change as much
as Hardware when it comes to you know
the vendor where you're buying that
harder sometimes you have the same
hardware which is supposed to be the
same thing but it works in a slightly
different way okay like sometimes they
have a button that works and it slightly
differently so out of these codes what
is really managed by Google and what is
really managed by the user by you know
yourself or the developer so we looked
at the first part so calm Google Android
things so the the core of Android things
is actually managed by Google
okay so Google came up with this whole
thing now the button which is the second
part if
can read that it says Android things
that contrib dot driver so this is a
contribution driver so this is someone
who wrote a driver for a button okay and
and the beauty of it is the drivers are
open-source if you don't think the
button works the right way or if you
don't like if you know happy with the
way it works or whatever you can just go
and make a pull request so the drivers
are open-source and in fact what's been
happening is a bunch of people have been
writing drivers so these are the current
contrib drivers so there's stuff like
GPS for example there's a there's a
temperature sensor there's an LCD
display their servos and there's quite a
few there's a so the one in the bottom
is a speaker so you have a bunch of
different drivers okay but what will
happen eventually is these lists of
driver which is not an extensive list
right now but these lists of drivers
eventually you're going to find yourself
needing something else you're going to
find yourself needing some different
driver if you are leaving source of like
the arduino world when you need a drip
when it needs a different driver you
basically unless it really goes with c
or c++ you're basically screwed okay now
in my case i wanted to you know i wanted
to see if it was possible for me to
create to create different drivers and I
found someone wrote a blog post showing
people how to write your first Android
things driver and then I had this idea
that I wanted to build something like
this this is a binary clock okay so it's
got a bunch of LEDs there it's got 18
LEDs on it and I wanted to build this I
wanted to build something that looks
like this and I was like well I think
Android things is like kind of the way
to go okay so I found that to run a
binary clock I needed a bunch of GPIO s
so I could communicate with all my LEDs
and why are the Androids
why are the the Arduino the sorry the
Raspberry Pi board has a bunch of
outputs and inputs I was going to have a
bunch of wires running over it it was
gonna be a mess okay so I wanted to do
it in a way that even if I wanted to
have two binary clocks running or three
binary clocks running
I would have enough GPIO okay and I knew
the raspberry PI's don't have an F GPIO
so I found this thing here we'll just go
to max seven two one nine the max seven
209 is basically a an LED driver that
lets you drive up to 64 LEDs and you can
also change them so you can have if you
have two 128 so you can keep on training
them up to I think seven so that's like
a lot of LEDs okay so I found that and I
was like perfect
this is what I want but there was no
driver for it okay so I went ahead and
created my own driver again I used the
language I already know I used Android
to create my own driver so this is all
written in I think this one is returning
I wrote this one in cotton yeah so again
it's the language I know and it's the
language that I am most comfortable with
so I just built a driver for it I went
to the documentation I saw how the thing
worked again I'm not an electrical
engineer so I had to you know spend some
time looking at this but hey I built a
driver and and the lesson here is like
it's really not that hard like it's
actually quite fun being a driver like
they especially I'm gonna get it working
it's actually quite fun now in terms of
what is managed by what so the stuff
that is managed by Google and the
differences between having Android
things running on a device like this or
having underthings running on a phone is
this this is what Android this when it
runs on a phone now when you move to
Android things you will notice that some
of these things disappear because
obviously now you can't use your
Raspberry Pi as a phone like even though
it's running Android you can't use that
as a phone you can't use that for
messaging your concepts or calendar
wallpapers like this is not what this
thing is meant for okay this is meant to
be a device that helps you building you
know Internet of Things as opposed to
like just building your phone if you
want a phone you get a phone obviously
you know there's like as you know the
lower you go so you've got the
application framework and then you've
got the Linux kernel which is basically
the same one that runs on Android right
the cool thing in here is this place are
completely optional and I know I told
you like you know when you set up your
Raspberry Pi you might want to connect
that to a display just to make sure
everything is working but they are
option
okay so you can completely survive
without a display the other thing here
is if you don't have a screen like if
you want to if you really want to test
it out where you don't really have a
screen you can use applications so this
is this is an application called visor
so if you don't have like an HDMI
display or something you can use
applications like visor to connect to
your Raspberry Pi device and again in
this case I'm showing like I'm running
an Android application which I'm gonna
which I'm going to talk to you about in
just a second so this application is
called doorbell so you can also mix and
match which is I find this really cool
like you can you can have a display so
the Raspberry Pi has displays like
external displays they can connects to
it and they're also touchscreens so you
can have both like you can have a
Android things device like a Raspberry
Pi device that has a an interface
components ways which it will build just
like your built in Android but you can
also do the hardware part of it so you
can mix a match which is kind of cool so
like theoretically you could every you
could have an external button just like
this but you could have an application
just like that that has a button in it
as well and they both do the same thing
but let's just look at let's just look
at another demo and this all of them
always one favorites of mine and I'll
tell you why because obviously the demos
I showed you today they're like you know
they're not they're not really real like
you know you know you're not gonna spend
your life just building
hello worlds with Android things but the
next one is a real one for me so the
next one is when I built when so I work
from home
most times I work from home and when I
work from home I listen to very loud
music okay listening to very loud music
means whenever there's like a postman at
the door for example I don't hear them
like I never do I'm on the first floor
of my house and I just don't hear
whenever there's someone at the door I
just don't hear them so what started to
happen was I was getting those like
notes asleep saying well yeah your
postman came over you weren't here so
now you need to go back to the post
office and get your stuff and this is
getting annoying you okay cuz like I was
in the house but I would never I would
just never hear the postman so what I
thought oh
okay so I I'm not downstairs and I'm not
gonna stop listening to music so like
it's impossible for me to know that the
postman is at the door however there's
one thing I always have in front of me
when I'm like when I'm working which is
my phone so I miss the postman every
single time but if you call me I never
miss a call because my phone is always
in front of me and I I bet everyone
works with the phone in front of them so
if you don't want records because you
don't want to answer but you know my
phone is always in front of me and I was
like can I do something about this like
can I build something that maybe when
the postman rings my doorbell I get a
call and that's what I built
so back to I'm gonna stop this and I am
gonna go ahead and remove so remember I
said I said Android things is a kind of
a one application only thing so what I
did here is I just uninstalled this
application and I'm gonna go to another
application I built and this one is
called doorbell things and what doorbell
things does is again it's an application
just like the one you've seen before it
has a if you it has a has an interface
for the doorbell so this is basically
how this basically the API use to make
an external request to an external
service like a you know make an HTTP
request okay now I built this service
application here and what it will do is
every single time you make a get request
to this application I built and when you
make the write get request and you're
passing the right things this is gonna
call my phone so I'm gonna get a call so
every single time you make a get request
I'm gonna get a call in here so the way
this thing works is super similar to the
one we had before so I have a
initialized doorbell button which pays
you know initializes this doorbell
Pressman low same kind of thing we
looked at before and when you when you
initialize that button
we initialize retro phases also retro
face is the thing we're using to make
HTTP requests and we have an event
listener for this button so every single
time we every single time we push this
button we're just making an HTTP request
and we're making the HTTP requests on
the way that my application my server
let's application on the other side will
know and will know to give me a call
okay
so if I now run this application on my
device on my Android things device so
imagine these okay it's really hard to
show you because like I wish I could
just bring my door here so you could see
my you know my doorbell and everything
but just like you know imagine this this
is like my door and the postman comes
over they've got a they've got a letter
for me this is what my doorbell will
look like okay so this is this is
roughly what my doorbell would look like
and I also have my phone here which I
should try and put it somewhere there
okay so I think you can see so now this
is the this is the the postman coming
over and the postman goes and rings my
doorbell okay so you may have seen at
the bottom there says but buts impressed
and hopefully again if the Wi-Fi is
working yeah I get a call so I answer
this call and it will say there's
somebody at the door so the cool thing
about this is again this was a fairly
cheap thing for me to build like I could
have gone invoice one of those like
fancy ring doorbells and everything but
it's not the same kind of fun like it's
not as fun as actually abusing my own
thing like I I built a doorbell how many
people can say that
so this is like you know this is where I
I kind of go crazy with my ideas and and
start like building stuff like this so
obviously you know I went and I built a
doorbell
but I also built I also built some
different things with this the other one
is how to build a high-five machine with
Android things so what I wanted to do is
every single time I got a like on
Twitter again that person works from
home and doesn't really talk to people
every single time I got a like from
Twitter I just wanted to get a high-five
so I built a high-five machine that
basically listens to my Twitter accounts
and whenever I get I like I get a little
high five
the other thing I built was controlling
your office lights of Android things so
this one is basically plugged into my
hue light so I've got the hue light
bulbs at home and I built something that
I can press the buttons and again these
are all like blog posts so under things
like rocks you see all this all the
codes and everything for this but I
built this thing that obviously I can
say Alexa turn the lights Reds I turned
the lights green but I just wanted to go
back I just wanted to go like analog and
I was like can I press a button it
sounds like green as it sounds out so
you can because the hue lights they have
an API and I can just make requests to
the API so you know some of the things
are going to be more useful than other
things but it's like what is useful to
you may not be you know useful to me but
it's cool to be able to have these
options and have things that you can
play with on that again Android things
is the power of Android it is managed by
Google okay so the part that is managed
by Google is really important and the
reason I say managed by Google is
important is if you are doing
over-the-air updates for example you
want to make sure that your over-the-air
updates are secure you want to make sure
that no one is intersecting that you
want to make sure that no one is
actually taking charge of your IOT
devices as you know instead of you like
we don't want to have an output another
botnets accident or something like this
so this being managed by Google kind of
stops that unless people get access your
Google accounts and it's also automatic
and secure and yes with that I've been
Markus Percona there's my Twitter
accounts there's my github accounts all
of the codes that
you've seen here you're gonna be able to
see them I get hub accounts and I also
run Android things like rocks and if you
want to come and talk to me about the
Esso you want to go comment on my box
video downstairs just by the coffee
place thank you very much
[Applause]